tal como la cuerda de un arco así se
estiró la tubería del oleoducto por el
que se filtraron decenas de miles de
litros de petróleo en el mar al sur de
california
tras una mayor investigación hemos
determinado que cerca de 1200 19 metros
de los 28 kilómetros de la tubería han
sido desplazados y lateralmente han sido
desplazados 0.3 metros y según las
primeras investigaciones el causante
pudo ser un ancla que se enganchó a la
tubería y provocó una ruptura parcial
además del segmento de tubería que fue
arrastrados media 1.2 kilómetros de
largo y tenía un corte de 30 centímetros
sin embargo no se dieron más detalles no
estoy acá para especular sobre la causa
habrá una investigación completa
obviamente la tubería ha sido desplazada
es una tubería de acero de 16 pulgadas
que tiene media pulgada de espesor y
está cubierta con una pulgada de
concreto
tras el corte miles de playas fueron
cerradas y la pérdida de especies
marinas es todavía incalculable por lo
que el gobernador del estado fue
terminante al hacer un llamado a innovar
la tecnología de extracción nos estamos
moviendo hacia un futuro más limpio y
verde este proceso se está desarrollando
lo que es importante notar es que la
economía en el estado de california
durante los últimos cinco años es la
economía de más rápido crecimiento de
todas las democracias occidentales a
medida que cambiamos la forma en que
producimos y consumimos energía las
perforaciones en alta mar ya se habían
restringido en el estado después de un
devastador derrame en 1969 en el que se
derramaron 80.000 barriles al océano